the wall is
breached fighting in the
passages screams of the dying yes dying
peasants though don't we think footsteps
coming
closer they're at the
door oh
dear humble Joan I challenge you to
single
combat a fighting Queen at
last
your throne is lost when I was a girl i'
watch my father punish traitors he would
cleave off their arms and shove them up
their asses that's nice and then he
would cleave off their asses and shove
those up whatever remained greetings
peasants your queen needs clothes my
name is bobic we'll walk to finger stone
rock to find new soldiers for the queen
you're going to need a horse they all
died a dragon then yet they're not
real
off someone's helping her someone clever
I was born in a bin when we were little
we couldn't have F close so we made our
own out of
nettles ouch that was my first
word it's all over for Queen danan
absolutely fantastic if I were to
compose a ranking list of my favorite
evil tyrants she never make top 20 let's
not be too hard on her nailed on bottom
five bottom two
even I have heard she looks here in the
East and she's done poos in your wealth
[Applause]
she doesn't do
[Music]
that please don't leave me second of
safety second of
safety eat my
jellyfish screw that who dares to defame
your queen think
first still alive
[Applause]
what
close it magnificent
outstanding last place is either danan
or Magnus of flator and Magnus did a lot
more charity work than people
remember sort of overshadowed you know
by the
flagellations